[Applause]
that makes you feel like you're
snuggling 100 puppies
[Laughter]
that's a cat all right and with me at
the desk is my trusty co-pilot roxy ross
matthews hi everybody
hi birthday girl and
joining us well it's her birthday too
and she's one of the finest comedic
geniuses of our time and you know her
from the snl hall of fame as well as so
many other beautiful credits rachel
dratch
happy birthday to you happy birthday
thank you but it'd be a great birthday
for someone for a baby to be born 2 22
22. so for all the babies popping out
today congratulations
and thanks for watching
we all try to keep track of all the
important birthdays in our lives but
sometimes we mess up and one mom in
minnesota bravely admits that she had
the wrong birthday for her
three-year-old son i love the story
people reports emily vondrachek says
she's only figured it out when her
insurance company had a different date
in their records they flagged it when
she went back to check her own birth
announcement on facebook she stood
corrected watch this his birthday is
indeed the 25th
for two years
i've been celebrating his birthday on
the 26th
and now i have to call my pediatrician
back and say haha you know what i had my
kid's birthday wrong you want to know
the worst part the worst part
it's my middle child
[Applause]
and why you know it's not great okay but
i'm not going to mom shame you i'm not
going to do it i will i thought about
angelina jolie didn't she get like
tattoos of the longitude latitude or the
birth dates of all her kids or something
that's a good idea or
if you don't want to do a tattoo you
could just be like hey siri you know
remember this day forever that'll work
too and i just will say you know parents
can do so many different things to screw
up their kids right if this is the worst
thing you did to your kid your kid's
gonna be fine don't worry about it
um all right ross your story all right
well next up you know one of the
buzziest shows on tv everyone's talking
about euphoria
and it just yes it just got picked up
for a season three so congrats to them
it's getting a ton of attention not just
for the teen drama but also for those
incredible aesthetics the wall street
journal reports even adults are taking
fashion cues from the teens of euphoria
they're inspired by the bold and sparkly
looks that have earned costume designer
heidi bivens two emmy nominations and
rachel so we actually took the liberty
of putting you in one of the looks from
euphoria there you go
that's what you would look like if you
euphoria out
yourself stretchy yeah i like that you
do yeah i i don't i don't give that much
thought to fashion except for today i
wore flowers for you but except for
today um no often i i i leave the house
in like a in a before picture you know
like
[Music]
you